training you watching this who
accidentally or
purposely pressed the video um i
challenge you to actually take politics
aside
take all the media aside take everything
aside you study
islam for what it is and study the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and see that it's not actually a
kind of like undisputed different thing
from buddhism it's actually so
so so similar and it's just believing in
the next prophet in line which was
prophesied to come
right and so um as we know
in the bible if you actually read the
bible or the old testament you will see
that
the prophets and the jewish or
israelites they are they were two
different things
because they did not necessarily always
accept the message and actually many
times they harmed the prophet
and so i i challenge you to
with an open heart and try to see
and acknowledge that god is still here
ready to accept you
and that um yeah to go into islam with
that with an open objective perspective
that's
my message and and if you guys
want or need any help i will also be
able to
to to help you guys so i'll answer
questions
and if there are any sincere ones
actually out there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companies came
to him and asked you know we're dealing
with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman
and think about it if you have
catastrophic
life-changing doubts about your religion
it can't be anything other than a sign
that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dhonia the three muslims podcast
today we're joined with a very special
guest
brother jonathan masha allah salaam
alaikum how are you doing
we're doing good what about you we're
good
so jonathan masha allah um you're one of
the
probably the only jewish convert to
islam
that i've ever heard about subhanallah
so let's get right into it
bro so how was your upbringing like
what's your story
in coming to islam yeah
so like as you said my story is probably
not like
the most usual one and i was born and
raised in norway
and my background is jewish from both my
father and mother's side and so like on
my father's side and
what's this like ashkenazi jewish is
european jewish he is from hungary
and from my mother's side he is
originally from iraq
in baghdad as far as i know my family on
both of these sites have lived there
and as far as they know and
so i was raised as a state in norway
with like
mostly a secular background but being
jewish
and getting like you know like that i'm
at yeah being raised up with a jewish
identity
but um so basically
uh i was a normal teenager basically
still am other than i'm like rivers
muslim
alhamdulillah and i have been
i was like a skateboarder for since i
was 14 years old
and i stayed for it was my many years
and i was in a state where i was a
skateboard instructor
uh i also became like very interested in
reason and music producing and this is
like before islam so i was
music producer produce music and like
that very much but
at the same time i used to read a lot
and use youtube a lot because um
i was like just a curious guy you know
very open i
also my family very open they had many
muslim friends
and and like those ones so i was like
i had a very open background and like
from the upbringing and um
basically i i had my fight so now i'm 20
years old
and i reverted when i was 18 years old
and before that i used to read a lot as
i said use a lot of youtube because
like i know that i can learn a lot from
anyone and just as you have a teacher
in front of you who can teach you
something i can learn something from
youtube and so
i just bring this into the discussion
because it helped me understand a lot
about
like religion and stuff because i had a
lot of questions
and basically um when i was 17 years old
i started requesting everything and like
um
started to see like um that
judaism for for example they do not
accept the true prophets of which
basically the whole world believes in
jesus
and so no i did not in any way doubt
like that judaism had some truth in it
because i knew that like they cannot
like
lie or that it shouldn't be that like
they have brought up a lie
in the traditions for for like many
years and so
although i knew that there was wasn't
twisted judaism my purpose
and my um like perspective was to
find out does islam and christianity
have any truth to them
and like naturally being like uh
like reading about jesus isla islam i
kind of
knew that he was the messiah although
you should not accept him as
the one but when i met islam
and i met islam basically very early but
i was not like considering it in any way
and like my story
meeting islam was that i had a friend
which
was norwegians norwegian and we were
like when we became friends we matched
entirely
we used to talk every night all the time
about all these philosophical
discussions and stuff
and we used to agree every time on the
discussion
and so we had a break in our
relationship and then uh
after some time we i heard that he was
muslim right
so i was like okay he's muslim did he
change his mind
from all of that we talked about you
know and so we met
again and thought and he did actually
say that all
of that we talked about and because we
shared a lot of knowledge
trying to you know get to the truth and
stuff and he said
all of that we talked about is islam i
became really curious about islam
and basically started to try requesting
it and learn
and even see if it is in some way like
faulty
and so i started to he showed me videos
and i i became like obsessed watching
many videos like the merciful servant
doctor zakir knight and many people
i i can't mention them all but
um after i saw like the miracles of
prophet muhammad follow
they would tell them and just realizing
that
they accept it muslims accept isla islam
is the messiah
and they even say isa is the messiah
sent to the syrian of israel
which it says in the quran so
and after like a lot of time with
already seeing that all of my beliefs
which i previously had held was in islam
i just it became actually pretty easy
for me to become a muslim and
one of the other philosophical things
which i actually believe before coming
to islam was that
i believe that all their religions they
have like um many similarities with
their life
and you see that because some religions
they have like uh heaven and hell
and some religions have like many
similarities which you see
and then you can start to see like maybe
they are from the same source and some
have been corrupted
and me believing in this before islam
says this i became like really shocked
when islam
actually uses this and has pieces for
like 1
500 years years and
this and many others one other thing i
want to mention is
that i as i said i i used juicy velocin
there was this priest
whose name was my recommended and i
watched him for some reason and
he gave like a really interesting view
about the world like
he said that like because many people
who argue against god they say
who created god right and then
that that's the fallacy actually the
argument is you can't make that argument
because
if god created time faith and matter
right
he cannot be created he is infinite
right he is outside of the creation
saying he
saying or asking that has he been
created it's like
it's basically assuming that he is in
dependence on
like dependent on time while he is not
and so
islam as the surah is
and so like alhamdulillah after meeting
islam and really i don't think it is
impossible to refute and allah
basically softens my heart and i became
muslim at ages 18 and i've been muslim
six years now so
that's like a brief story and every time
i tell it it's different
but at least you know a bit for now
bro i could literally it sounded like a
little like mini trailer into your life
so do you think that because i find with
a lot of
uh people who practice judaism they are
a lot more
reluctant when it comes to like
accepting other religions and they're
very just
you know firm on judaism right and i
don't really blame them necessarily
because this is a religion that
is an ethnocentric religion it's not
just a religious um
it's not just religious ideology and
belief it's actually the fact that they
are ethnically jewish as well
um so i could see why they wouldn't want
to but with that being said it doesn't
take away from the fact that they're all
very
firm on it and reluctant to really look
at or accept other religions so
do you think the fact that your parents
were a little more secular had a role to
play in you being more open towards
other religions
yeah that's definitely a good question
and it is
most likely very true and my family
and like now i'm talking about my and
their closest one mother and father
brother and sister
and they all know i'm muslim now and
alhamdulillah
what helped me uh explaining to them and
they know i muslim and i have a really
good relationship with them actually
but basically having that upbringing
where
my father and mother would not basically
they they wouldn't
enforce the religion on us they would
like teach us and
tell us that this is like our history as
like jewish
people but if i would want to convert to
another religion
and they would be accepting others now
and of course me converting to islam was
quite
like a shock for them but when i
explained to them what islam really was
they it changed their mind because of
course in the west we have like
an a distorted perception of islam and
to be honest i even had that before
and that's also some of the reasons why
i was like shocked because you know
you you think you know islam but when
you go into it
objectively you see that islam is
beautiful
not the islam which for the the force of
people which is not islam but islam
in its core and prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it's beautiful and it's pure goodness
and
if if the only thing is people who who
doubt
uh who interpret it incorrectly and
who do not um do not know or argue there
were not good examples right but
basically
it had a lot to say and i knew that even
though i was
muslim because my parents are as they
are they would accept
accept it so of course it helps a lot
yeah
i have a question for angel no anho you
being a reaver yourself
do you see any similarities any
differences anything you want to know
uh there's a few there's a few for sure
i had a question bro
what would you tell a jewish person
who claims themselves to be jew
you know they they follow judaism uh
they were born into it
yet their parents drink alcohol
and he drinks alcohol and
it you look at his lifestyle and it's
just like really far from
at least what judaism is is trying to
practice here we're trying to show
people what to practice
what would you tell the jewish person at
that point
yeah so of course i have my opinions on
this
and i have things in a lot of things
but basically um the thing is about
judaism
as um romney said it is both
like a religion and it is an ethnicity
right and so
because it also is very old it's 5000
years old
like the judaism we have today it's not
it's not truly like
the core of what the prophet sees it's
it has
remnants right um the prophet sees upon
him it has remnants of that
but today it's it's been like so
interpreted
in like incorrectly and like not only
that it doesn't need to be like
um with some purpose evil purpose but
people and translations and everything
has changed it and we know this because
we're muslim
but uh specifically specifically to your
uh christians you know that you can
actually be atheists
and jewish and for me that is such
such illogical and i actually almost
become like angry like
you cannot be jewish and atheist in my
opinion but according to like
rabbinical rabbis and judaism you can
and and as as such you have like as like
a jewish tradition which
can be like has most people who are
secular
and has most people who are um not
believing in god but they they tell
themselves to be jews
and another thing which i found to be
really
like troublesome is that some some jews
not all and
this is minority but some jews they
claim to be like the chosen people
and then they say that therefore this
this land is ours right the land of
israel
but they and then at the same time they
say they don't believe in god
and then like when i like started
thinking like this i was like
this is hypocrisy you know and allah
subhanahu zaha
tells us a lot about hypocrites in the
quran
and so i'm totally i've separated myself
from
like politics as a whole but also like
this the situation
and but either way like alcohol
also it's like uh it's a debate
in in judaism in in the bible i think
we have clearly that it says that it's
forbidden but we have like
a rabbi saying that oh it should take
like
like now that's so high in mouth you
don't become intoxicated then it's okay
and this is similar to christianity but
as uh
in my opinion of course it is
forbidden and to drink alcohol
and i do not know personally if at some
point it was allowed
and then it was changed and all i know
is that we drink
actually drink my wine in the shabbat
like the the holy friday
this is actually included in our rituals
to drink wine
and i grew up with drinking like crew
health but like
seeing my family having wine like on the
holy day though yeah that's crazy man
that's
[Music]
um i feel like anyone who
uh tries to bend the rule and be like oh
well you know what i i can drink alcohol
like a little bit
as long as i don't get intoxicated i
feel like all these people
just end up taking it over the top
anyways and they get drunk
and then it's like they try to say oh
well i'm a sinner that's why
i was drunk like no bro well maybe you
shouldn't have drank in the first place
you know maybe you shouldn't have drank
but the answer
fire's question um a similarity i see
with you is uh when you said that your
parents were just shook
when you told them that you became
muslim um but
the only difference is that the only one
of my parents
that kind of was like curious as to like
why
i chose islam was my dad and even then
like i haven't really been able to
talk to him about this insha allah i'll
be able to within the next few days
next few months um but my mom man like
my mom she just
like she was completely against it and
to this day she
she doesn't ask any questions she
doesn't she's not curious about
it at all so i don't know bro
a lot of wills where he wills and guys
who he was
yeah indeed i'm the love bro
i got a question for you jonathan so a
lot of people i know
when they're reverts intellectually
submitting to islam is enough for them
right other people even though logically
they're sold
in a way right or intellectually they
don't feel it
they don't feel that connection so for
you was it more of like a logical thing
because i know for someone like myself
the logical thing has to come first i
have a lot of questions i have a lot of
skepticism
once that's addressed then i can feel it
after
so what was it for you that's a good
question too i actually gladly brought
it up
and and i wanted to explain it i
explained that
actually like so my um um river story or
like way coming to islam was strictly uh
like
logical or intellectual one so
i guess if in my opinion i use them both
as the same thing like
it was a rational rational way of coming
to islam because all the questions i had
were answered
and it was not like i had any i was
going into it objectively
just analyzing it trying to see if it's
not true but it is true and it was
i thought it was true because like
although also i knew that
like some part of you doesn't have to be
true i knew some part of christianity
had to be true
and then islam is the religion which
accepts both
prophet islam islam and suffered muslim
muslim is the one
mentioned most in the quran so
like it became very easy for me but it
was strictly a rational one
and uh although i did not necessarily
like have any
um i didn't necessarily want to become
muslim at any point in my life
i just i just knew that i wanted to to
what is the truth
and i had actually said to myself a
couple of months before
when i was like curious about stuff and
read a lot of stuff i was like if i find
something to be the truth
i will stand for it even if the whole
world is against me
so this is like the main position for me
to become a muslim those facts
bro before anyone chimes in asking
another question i just gotta throw this
out there man another similarity i see
when you were talking about uh your your
friend at the time
the one that you were real close to when
you guys would talk about these things
um i had the same thing bro i had a best
friend at the time
who like i'm still still talking to this
day but when i became muslim
um like our relationship just kind of
drifted apart
and he he asked questions
because he he's also seeking the truth
as well but he
he claims that he's seeking the truth
yet he's actually
hindu he says he's not hindu but he does
all the hindu practices like he was born
hindu
um he's indian so it's like that's his
culture that's what he grew up in
but it's like he claims he's not hindu
but he he worships
the idols and you know shiva and
uh ganesh and all this stuff so it
for me i guess the similarities like we
have that but then again like
he was uh brought away versus like
you being the friend that was like oh
curious and then look at you now and now
you're both in islam
yeah that's uh alhamdulillah so he
became a friend before me
and like i that's probably
a big reason why i became a friend
because he helped me a lot uh he teached
me
islam and actually he knew arabic
although he's truly norwegian he
he had studied arabic in his high school
because it was
actually a language and so when his
position studying arabic
and being very like essentially a very
smart guy and he
basically of course he missed the quran
at some point traveling and stuff
he accepted islam and that was around
the time we had a break in our
relationship
and so like truly being like
as we said talking and disgusting and
we we both agreed to that islam was
truthful although he before me
so bro tell me about some notable
moments if you have any that you want to
share
to our viewers of when you truly felt
something with islam or allah not more
logical stuff
but more like something maybe during
salah during sajud like something where
you first felt like
something real something spiritual not
tangible
that could be question it will be hard
to actually
find uh there are because there are a
lot of things
but um like i i remember
uh when i first heard that there had
been
124 000 prophets and
this was like uh something which i
find really astonishing because god has
guided humankind many times right and
humans have their done stood up to the
prophets
killed them or corrupted the teachings
or just this is because like this is
what happens we find that people will
eventually
you know dissolve but um when i
found that islam was like such a
beautiful religion which
like it is a religion which wants you to
be the best of character
right and it is it was like
when i first though had had all my
questions answered
i became so like i had this uh
you know fear of god because he sees
everything now and
i had become muslim now i need to live
by
islam and there is no way back
and i i am glad that i've chosen this
path because
we cannot uh exchange the dunya for the
hereafter
um but you know seeing how they
respected all the prophets
of already like which i had already
learned about in judaism
and that muhammad sallallahu that would
tell them was final one
and the perfect one and the one sent to
all mankind
and the one prophesized in both both
scriptures
actually both bible and old testament
several times and for me it was like
my heart became softened you know
i don't know if i did answer your
question no that was perfect bro that's
that was good that was good bro uh but
question for you
what was uh one of the hardest things
you experience
reverting
made it easy for me but what i thought
was the hardest
thing was to tell my family and like
changing all my previous habits
and all my life because as i said i was
like a skateboarder
i was a music producer and
i had basically stopped music producing
like
to the degree i did and uh i have
stopped now
but um the hardest thing was to like
give or give up those things for islam
but as
as again if you give up something for
islam allah will give you something
better
and i truly believe that and he helped
me
help me a lot uh as i said making my
family accept it with no problem at all
um and um so the hardest thing was
definitely like being
open and like telling everyone about it
or like
you know that i was like yelling it out
so that it's
all the people who i knew before and all
the comics are also coming from the
jewish background it is
pretty pretty like unique as a
or like special to become muslim but for
me it's
easy it's rational it's the only thing
which has been preserved
the quran for example and so
it's not it's not like so difficult for
me because if they want they can come
and try to
debate with me and or with animals them
and see if their hearts is um
don't have the whale over them that they
will
eventually see that you know if they
speak it through it as
uh as uh angel said if if they do not
speak to the truth then they will not
see it
you know a lot of people are on that
boat
and they're scared bro they're scared
that what if islam really is the truth
what if what if islam really is it and
then subconsciously they just resist it
because
there's too much of a paradigm shift and
then they go around saying no i can't be
real
there's that another about your prophet
your god every time i hear that it's
just
like when uh when rami was debating that
that brother i don't know if you saw
that debate
on saturday rami had a debate with an
atheist and he kept saying
your god your god and i was just like
what do you mean you're a god bro
but then again so they won't understand
that
yes um
all right i have a question for you now
do you have any
message for all the the jews practicing
and non-practicing out there
yeah i have actually if you have
friends watching this who accidentally
or
purposely press the video um i challenge
you
to actually take politics aside
take all the media aside take everything
aside to study
islam for what it is and study the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and see that it's not actually a
kind of like undisputed different thing
from judaism it's actually so
so so similar and it's just believing in
the next prophet in line which was
prophesied to come
right and so um as we know
in the bible if you actually read the
bible or the old testament you will see
that
the prophets and the jewish or
israelites they are they were two
different things
because they did not necessarily always
accept the message and actually many
times
they harmed the prophet and so i i
challenge you to with an open heart
and try to see and acknowledge that god
is still here ready to accept you and
that
um yeah to go into islam with that with
an open objective perspective that's
my message and and if you guys
want or need any help i will also be
able to
to to help you guys so i'll answer
questions
and uh if there are any sincere ones
actually out there
i and where can they find you
if they have questions well they can
email me for example and take it from
there
so yeah you can leave it in the
description or something like that
100 bro i'll put the email in the
description box
so do you do you uh still skateboard
or did you give that up along with the
music
no i actually do still skateboard just
to get some activity going but it's not
the same way
but i just still do it and it's fun um
but not that the same like a mouse that
i did previously though
so let me ask yeah my bad for
interrupting here but you said the
amount that you used to do previously
like
how much were you skateboarding and what
was your intention
with the skateboarding were you trying
to like go pro with it or something
um i did not intend to go pro but like
there was like of course the time i had
that will
uh but my intention was to become like
good in contests and maybe win maybe
earn some money
and maybe get some sponsors you know uh
but
i did not get any sponsors but i did
actually work as a skateboard instructor
and that gave me some income
and as like when i find something
interesting
i go all in and that's like all all of
what i do
thinking about that continuously and so
this was me with skateboarding and me
with
music producing and now me with islam
yeah this man's profile picture is so
unprovoked too
the reason i asked man is because uh
actually i won't even say bro i'm not no
this is your podcast this is your ep
bro hmm i'm not gonna sing nothing
speaking of
this being your episode on our podcast
tell us how you found
t3m yeah
i i don't remember like exactly when
but i guess it popped out as a
recommended
probably uh with some of the guys who
are like more known
and i watched sometimes the guy
gabrielle
romani is good and actually i thought he
had a recent video
i saw also the cryptocurrency video it's
really interesting
and a couple of others probably like i
clicked on some of the
ones i already know and i saw you guys
and i think i also saw the river story
of
angel some time ago and felt really like
related to what he said about um as the
friends
and also that the spiritual path to find
his tourism stuff you know
masha allah
any uh any closing thoughts um
no to be honest i'm i'm just happy my
shot i finally found a uh
uh someone who used to be jews that
converted islam subhan allah i used to
discuss with this one jewish lady on
tick tock and
uh she she's uh she's pretty stubborn
she's pretty stubborn
so may allah bless you bro thank you
thank you and um yeah
that's as we said like from you say
they do not necessarily believe in
judaism although they say they're jewish
and some of them do and that's good i
just challenge them to
actually want to know the truth about
other prophets
you know which they do not accept they
haven't necessarily even thought about
why they don't accept them
and so it's just naturally you know
you want to be in the right position of
god almighty
and so yeah at least it was easy for me
any final thoughts from youtube that's
it man
that's it i'm very fortunate that
one you had the courage to come on the
podcast because a lot of people they
don't want to put this stuff out there
and they don't want to you know they
don't want to say oh what if people find
out this or what if you know
it's kind of like i see that a lot in
let's say different
cults and yes i called it a cult but
when you see ahmadi brothers or sisters
they finally find the truest song right
like suni-sun and they want to come
and make a video and they're like oh no
what if my family sees this what if i
you know i'm getting a lot of money from
this i might be on the streets right
so for you you know you put that aside
you came here to spread truth may allah
reward you immensely for that
i mean that's one number two i'm glad
that
allah has and continues to guide
lots of different people from different
religions different countries different
cultures
which really shows that if everyone's
coming to this one thing there must be
something there
right there's a was a video that uh on
the fresh and fit podcast with uh
i think his name was andrew tate all
right and he was saying uh
he's an orthodox christian by the way
and muhammad hijab posted a snippet of
that and he was saying if i had to bet
on one religion like i was betting on
the stock market
it would have to be islam and they were
asking why and he was like
well because islam is the only one where
people are intolerant not in a bad way
but they're intolerant to
modernism liberalism feminism lgbt all
this
right they're very intolerant in a way
where if you're tolerant to everything
you stand for nothing
that's what he said and it reminds me of
how
you know in judaism yes there's still
some orthodox jews
you know may allah guide them may have
blessed them there's still some orthodox
christians
there are some orthodox hindus but in
most religions
not to make a generalization they are
following a watered-down version
of their teachings which is what was
kind of getting to with the hinduism
thing
i don't really find that with sunni
islam i'm just islam as a whole i really
don't find that
and if i do it's probably because they
weren't taught right or
a lot of social programming yeah
i actually have a bit more to say so for
example
all of us and no matter where it's
religion we have our parents
most likely following a religion and as
again this is also central in islam he
thinks you have to question them because
it doesn't mean it is the truth
right the prophet abraham abraham lay
islam
his father was a politicist right or
idol worshipper but he
was firm on the monastery and right and
so we should
question our parents because we because
we see everyone has
parents and they all believe in
different things and
allah continues to guide people all over
the world and it is like the most
uh the religion
how do we say it increases in people who
come into the faith
every day and so obviously
he guides people because he
wants us to to find him you know
and one one more thing
um yeah
that was basically it yeah okay no
worries bro
yeah guys if you made it this far
hashtag
write down below in the comments come to
the truth and jessica here to brother
jonathan for making the time to speak
your truth and spread the message of
islam even further
may allah bless you all right there's
nothing else with that being said
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
basically when a group of companions
came to him and asked you know we're
dealing with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophets he said
that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
you